we were talking about how delusional you  are continue you're saying that the guy  that makes 10 20 million he could do  whatever he wants can he do any wrong no  cheat on you anything oh he's the last  to be accountable to me I'm sorry he's  giving you an allowance and you're  driving a G wagon why is he still  accountable and and he's getting but I'm  raising his children so he's getting  that [ __ ] so what do you have like a  magical [ __ ] that like has leprechauns  coming out of it I honestly do you  should hit him  this is what I say when I say women want  to be sold a dream  cheat on you oh come on at least she  gets it she she knows what Rich problems  come with I think ideally no one wants  anyone it's not a unicorn I think a lot  of women would put up with it